Street songs in Paris in the year 1749
and 1749 was a critical political year,
the government fell, why did it fall,
well the answer, according to all contemporaries
is because of songs, chanson.
Frere Blanche, that's what did the job.
The songs became a kind of sung newspaper
full of information and commentary
at a time when there were no real newspapers,
in the modern sense of the word, in Paris
and at a time when
certainly over half of the population was illiterate.
so songs, in other words, were perfect
as a means of communication
of oral communication.
People would invent
new words to old tunes
people would add a new verse to the old verses
as the politics developed
so because everyone kept these tunes in their heads
they were easy to remember.
Music is a kind of pneumonic device
and therefore
new verses to the old tunes
spread like wild fire through the streets of Paris.
Singers were arrested and
and the government tried to repress
some of the more disrespectful songs
or some of the more downright seditious songs.
Most oral communication of course
disappeared into the air
but the songs were recorded in these
song books, or chanson livret
and fortunately they can be studied.